io il problema o meglio le possibilità
diciamolo presa da un'altra direzione il
treno giorno di università di disegno
industriale e quello che ho studiato uno
dei professori intervenuto con questa
frase che il prodotto più sostenibile
che mai riuscirete a progettare in
realtà è quello che non verrà mai
prodotto e questo da un lato messo
subito su di noi giovani designer la
responsabilità che abbiamo oggi nel
dover creare qualcosa di nuovo per
infatti anche solo il fatto di creare
qualcosa di nuovo diventa quasi un
problema e questo è dettato da uno dei
grandi dilemmi il discorso della
material scarcity o comunque della
scarsità di risorse infatti ci troviamo
oggi a dover fronteggiare un sistema in
cui dove ci rendiamo conto che si
energia energia aliment alimenti non
bastano e soprattutto anche i prodotti
che abbiamo magari non sono abbastanza
per tutti quelli che saremo è infatti
quello l'interesse riguarda la
sostenibilità è più che altro sul non è
sull'oggetto stesso quindi sull'energia
sui sui materiali ma dal mio punto di
vista sul rapporto che abbiamo con gli
oggetti quindi sul valore che diamo agli
oggetti su come gli oggetti cambiano la
nostra vita e come gli oggetti stessi
abbiano un comportamento nostra vita una
grande ispirazione mi è venuta non da un
design non da uno scienziato ma da uno
scrittore che william burroughs uno
degli esponenti della beat generation
che parla della della dipendenza
generale della società odierna rispetto
al consumo
infatti dice che la società lavora in un
certo senso come lavora una dipendenza
dalla droga infatti il consumismo
compulsivo è dettato è generato non solo
dagli oggetti stessi ma in generale dal
contesto attorno a noi e quindi crea
questa questa sorta di velocità di
cambiamento necessità di sempre qualcosa
di nuovo e di più
infatti possiamo quasi dire che che
siamo siamo dipendenti da quello che
abbiamo
e come una dipendenza infatti il abbiamo
una sorta di piacere quando compriamo
qualcosa di nuovo si crea una sorta di
gratificazione che in un certo senso è
spinta dalle persone attorno a noi ha
sempre cercare un qualcosa di più quindi
la la peer pressure quello che viene il
confronto con le persone attorno a noi
ci crea cessità di volere di più di
voler sempre nuovi oggetti sempre sempre
qualcosa di nuovo di migliore e questo è
un problema che visto che io stesso che
sono penso di voler cambiare non sono in
grado di fronteggiare perché spesso ci
ci concentriamo nel curare le persone
ovvero nell'andare a a trovare delle
soluzioni per cui questa persona come
come un dipendente debba cambiare ma in
realtà senza la volontà interiore come
sappiamo dagli studi sulle dipendenze
sull'alcol sulle droghe senza una
volontà interiore questo questo sforzo è
vano
quindi quello che ho pensato è di fare
un qualcosa di totalmente opposto e di
pensare invece dal punto di vista
dell'oggetto stesso
e pensare che se questo oggetto avesse
una pressione esterna e quindi volesse
essere utilizzato perché il piacere di
un oggetto stesso è quello di essere
utilizzato
allora magari questo oggetto vorrebbe
avere più persone quindi vorrebbe essere
utilizzato di più per fare ciò ho preso
ad esempio un tostapane un tostapane uno
di quegli oggetti che diciamo nello
sfondo delle nostre vite un po anonimo e
ce ne accorgiamo solo quando non
funziona d'altro un altra cosa
interessante è che è un oggetto sempre
presente nelle visioni dell'internet of
things quindi degli oggetti connessi ma
in una maniera molto particolare perché
sempre funziona quando l'allarme e cc
dal pane nel momento giusto ma in realtà
questo non e non dal non darò la visione
su quello che potrebbe essere aver
oggetti connessi e intelligenti
infatti se pensiamo a dare un oggetto
veramente intelligente
magari questo oggetto non
non fare non farebbe quello che noi
vogliamo magari farebbe qualcosa che non
ci aspettiamo e quest'idea appunto l'ho
portato avanti
se prendiamo il punto di vista di un
tostapane come ogni oggetto il suo
piacere deriva dall'essere utilizzato
quindi nel caso del tostapane tostare
pane e nel momento in cui mettiamo
questo oggetto in un network quindi con
la possibilità di confrontarsi con altri
oggetti
questo tostapane può rendersi conto del
fatto di essere utilizzato più o meno e
quindi questo può dare il là a questa
differenza a questa questa sorta di
dipendenza determinata da una sorta di
di non soddisfazione interiore
per fare ciò però un oggetto deve avere
una sorta di di concetto quindi di per
poter contare nel poter sapere quanto
utilizzate avere un cervello ma diciamo
che se un arduino che ho utilizzato
inoltre deve deve avere un modo di
comunicare di poter di poter vedere cosa
ci attorno e quindi a una un ethernet è
un sensore di posizione per poter in
qualche modo parlare con network in
qualche modo vedere cosa c'è attorno è
anche un modo per comunicare in questo
caso un motore che crea una sorta di
linguaggio perché l'unica cosa che un
tostapane fu fare e muovere la propria
leva e quindi una dipendenza quindi un
network di questi sosta pani potrebbe
sembrare qualcosa del genere
come vedete quando uno ha utilizzato gli
altri cominciano un po a lamentarsi
piuttosto pani vengono utilizzati sulla
situazione peggiora fino a un punto di
di totale crisi quindi il a questo punto
mi sono fatto una domanda che mi son
chiesto oltre a una normale diciamo un
oggetto normalmente ha solo un modo per
comunicare con noi che la sua fisica
lita ma nel momento in cui un oggetto e
connesse quindi ha la possibilità di
parlare al di fuori della sua fisica
lita questo oggetto potrebbe diciamo
parlare con gli oggetti attorno a lui a
cercare di utilizzarli per essere
utilizzato di più quindi quello che la
domotica fa quindi connettere tutti gli
oggetti tra di loro ovviamente potrebbe
anche parlare con oggetti simili a lui e
quindi cominciare in qualche modo a
lamentarsi con loro ma allo stesso tempo
potrebbe anche raggiungere persone al di
fuori quindi altri altre persone che
magari vorrebbero utilizzarlo oppure il
panettiere per richiedere più pane ad
esempio ci sono tutte diverse
interazioni che possono nascere come ad
esempio
la necessità di calmare un tostapane un
oggetto oppure il tostapane stesso
potrebbe cominciare a attraverso un'app
chiederci di essere utilizzato in remoto
una sorta di metadone
oppure addirittura utilizzare gli
schermi per mandare dei messaggi
subliminali che ci convincano
utilizzarlo o addirittura potrebbe
corrompere il frigorifero il famosissimo
frigo intelligente che ci dice quando fa
la spesa e dirci quando comprare più
pane per essere utilizzato di più quindi
quello che abbiamo fatto in
collaborazione con uno studio a londra è
quello di creare un vero servizio quindi
vedere cosa cosa se questi oggetti
fossero al di fuori cosa potrebbe
succedere e quindi ho creato questo un
servizio in cui questi oggetti questi
tostapane non possono essere comprati ma
sono solamente ospitati dalle persone
una un interfaccia permette ad
iscriversi e di vedere come tostapane si
misurano in colonne di pane tra di loro
ovviamente è una persona può cercare di
iscriversi e convincere uno di questi
oggetti del fatto di essere un possibile
utente interessante quindi in base a
quante persone nel suo spazio quanti
tostapane ha già e questo in qualche
modo dare una misura un oggetto di
capire quanto noi siamo interessanti
come possibili utenti prestito sap hana
infatti poi se venivano mandati
direttamente alle persone connessi alla
rete e quindi cominciare a discutere tra
di loro ogni tostapane infatti ha una
propria personalità un nome un canale di
twitter perchè era la cosa più semplice
per poter comunicare con le persone e
quindi diciamo una propria personalità
quindi ad esempio come vediamo il
successo che alcuni tostapane hanno
chiesto se c'era qualcuno che voleva un
po di toast oppure a intimare il proprio
utente di andare a comprare del pane e
le persone stesse hanno cominciato a
interagire quindi ha intanto direi
welcome to
dove siamo oppure anche anche a
chiedersi cosa cosa fosse questa cosa la
cosa importante che però questi visto
che c'è stata un po di richiesta i
tostapane
non soddisfatti potevano chiedere a me
direttamente mandandomi una mail di
essere mandati un'altra persona quindi
ho preso questo ragazzo e ho cominciato
a farlo andare a prendere i toscani e
portali da un'altra persona con alcuni
problemi ma quindi abbiamo lasciato per
per un po di tempo questi tostapane in
giro per londra e quello che è successo
più o meno questo ad esempio uno di
questi cercando di prendere attenzione
ma fallendo miseramente in qualche modo
cominciare a reagire a interagire con le
persone attorno
attorno a lui e addirittura in certi
casi alcune persone hanno hanno
organizzato un party per far sì che
avessero più tosto e quindi il tostapane
non se ne andasse e vero qualcuno anche
qualcuno anche tra stato e ha cominciato
a usarlo per finta quindi ho dovuto una
persona addirittura ha cercato di
convincere l'ufficio del primo ministro
inglese ad averne uno ma ovviamente per
motivi di spionaggio non siamo riusciti
a mandarglielo ma già questa è una
tesoro
quindi addirittura una dei uno dei
vecchi ospiti non si sentiva più degno
del tostapane quindi per concludere
quello che voglio dire è che si apra si
apra noi diciamo un mondo di possibilità
in cui possiamo progettare oggetti che
hanno hanno dei comportamenti proprio
che possono farci cambiare anche idea su
sul nostro consumo e quindi magari nel
futuro anziché anziché avere pine power
anziché avere
anziché poter comprare oggetti dovremmo
invece trattenerli
quindi questo è un cambiamento e
concludendo quello che voglio dire è che
se funziona e che in realtà molto spesso
ci concentriamo a progettare prodotti di
successo che le persone possiedono a
mano ma magari nel futuro quello che
dobbiamo fare invece e progettare
prodotti che con successo sono amati
grazie mille